Friedrich Nietzsche one of the most
significant philosophers of all time
his name has been connected to a myriad
of ideas and his reputation has crossed
the limits of Europe to infect the rest
of the world Nietzsche is a man that has
influenced my views and beliefs to the
core and also a source of inspiration
and soothing whenever I feel lost in
need of direction today I will attempt
something I wanted for a long time I
will try to paint a picture of this
legendary figure while analyzing one of
his most interesting works human all too
human
I bought this classic while losing
myself in the endless status of a local
bookstore it kind of seduced me the
moment I saw it it was an instinctive
form of seduction that sprang from my
visceral need to have a part of
Nietzsche with me wherever I travel this
monumental pamphlet encompasses most of
the conundrums faced within the human
psyche and attempts to describe and
analyze them in a philosophical way it
is packed with powerful Maxim's that
illustrate Nietzsche's unparalleled
ability to scrutinize human nature and
offer concrete and oftentimes poetic
advice on how to deal with it
Friedrich Nietzsche in human all too
human investigates various areas of
human life in an attempt to create a
coherent philosophical framework the can
offer solid advice the problems we all
face his writing style is dense and
unique he uses very colorful language
and plays with words like a master
craftsman plays with his tools often
times a gravity of his psyche and the
psychological tension of his world seem
palpable in his sentences the advantages
of psychological observation that
meditating on things human all too human
is one of the means by which man can
ease laughs burden that by exercising
this art one can secure presence of mind
in difficult situations and
entertainment amid boring surroundings
indeed that from the thorniest and
unhappiest phases of one's own life one
can pluck Maxim's and feel a bit better
thereby the benefits of psychological
observation that is the ability to
observe and understand once motives and
actions
cannot be understated more often than
not were lost within the banality of
superfluous acts and we fail to realize
how we're Nespresso span of our lives
psychological duration is such a
powerful tool that can offer presence of
mind
amid difficult situations and amusement
during boring encounters this happens
because we manage to approach things
from a more analytical perspective and
allow ourselves to control the narrative
of its circumstance too close if we live
in too close proximity to a person it is
as if we kept touching a good edging
with our bare fingers one day we have
poor dirty paper in our hands and
nothing more a human being soul is
likewise worn down by continual touching
at least it funny appears that way to us
we never see its original design and
beauty again one always loses by all to
intimate association with women and
friends and sometimes one loses the
pearl of his life in the process and
this Maxim Friedrich Nietzsche
highlights an idea expressed by many
thinkers across history familiarity
kills respect and in a romantic
relationship even lust constant exposure
to the everyday nuances of another
person may breathe discomfort and a lack
of respect towards the other person's
competences Nietzsche logically draws
inspiration for this Maxim from the sad
endings most of his relationships had to
face he was a wild contrarian and could
easily express himself in provocative
ways that would unavoidably cause
friction and conflict moreover whenever
he would allow others to taste a part of
his vulnerable character he wouldn't
receive the appreciation he would expect
in turn he would grow resent toward both
others and himself for allowing too much
proximity to poison their kinship the
struggle is real and it manifests itself
in different ways throughout our lives I
think that the reason such concerns are
expressed so often is that we usually
fail to strike a balance between
pragmatism and romanticism these two
forces are mutually exclusive but but
does not necessarily suggest that we
can't successfully vacillate between the
two the key here is self honesty and the
establishment of pragmatic expectations
on
levels of our relationships the
hour-hand of life life consists of rare
isolated moments of the greatest
significance and of innumerably many
intervals during which that best the
silhouettes of those moments hover about
us love springtime every beautiful
melody mountains the moon the sea all
this be completely to the heart but once
if in fact they ever do get the chance
to speak completely for many men do not
have those moments at all and are
themselves intervals intermissions in
the symphony of real life this offer is
me remind me of Richard Dawkins opening
lines and unweaving the rainbow we're
going to die and that makes us the lucky
ones most people are never going to die
because they are never going to be born
experiencing life in its totality is a
challenging endeavor to say the least
that is because we become entangled in
the so-called earthly issues of the
daily grind and we failed to recognize
the vastness of various experiences life
can offer ego is the enemy here and it
creates a trap we desperately failed to
see this ego trap is only present and
thus our willingness to its self
transcendence becomes a distant hope
Mitch identified this conundrum early on
in his life and realized how much of an
impact it can have on limiting one's
perception when Nietzsche says during
which at best the silhouettes of those
moments hover about us he clearly wants
to emphasise how bland we have become in
our attempt to identify moments of Extra
Ordinary significance hence our
propensity to experience grandiosity is
predicated on how easily we allow
ourselves to surrender to the simplicity
and complexity of those moments the ones
that do surrender are the ones who fill
their lives with the innumerable
intervals of significance the ones that
don't become themselves the intervals
and intermissions
learning to love we must learn to love
learn to be kind and this from earliest
youth if education or chance gives us no
opportunity to practice these feelings
our soul becomes dry and unsuited even
to understanding the tender inventions
of loving people likewise hatred must be
learned and nurtured if one wishes to
become a proficient hater otherwise the
germ for that too will gradually wither
it might be just me but I sense a degree
of irony in this particular maxim this
is something not so common in me just
works so I'm a bit reserved apropos my
interpretation I'm mainly referring to
the last sentence of the aphorism where
he mentions that hatred must be learned
and nurtured if one wishes to become a
proficient hater otherwise the germ for
that too will gradually wither this
interesting remark alludes to the
possibility that hate is a perpetual
state of discontent that can be
nourished just like every other state
known to men one isn't born full of hate
or full of love but according to one's
influences he or she can cultivate a
biased sense of how to perceive the idea
of love and hate the irony in the last
remark lies in the use of a term
proficient when describing a haters
ability to hate for some exercising hate
might even reach a professional level
and could create a level of dependency
on the catastrophic feeling however
Nietzsche identifies that this exercise
is a conscious one and that most of the
time it is pursued rather than randomly
acquired with regards to love Nietzsche
puts emphasis on the idea that love
needs to be learned
indeed love although it is considered
the preeminent feeling it also
constitutes one of our most arduous
quests love isn't something that
transpires organically love is something
that needs to be cultivated if this
fails to occur one will lack the
capacity to show love and most possible
he or she will be oblivious to the love
offered by those who actually know how
to exercise it
boredom and play need forces us to do
the work whose product will quiet the
need we're habituated to work by the
ever new awakening of needs but in those
intervals when our needs are quieted and
seem to sleep boredom overtakes us what
is that it is the habit of working as
such which now asserts itself as a new
additional need the need becomes a
greater the greater our habit of working
perhaps even the greater our suffering
from our needs to escape boredom man
works either beyond what his usual needs
require or else he invents play that is
work that is designed to quiet no need
other than that for working in general
he who is tired of play and has no
reason to work because of new needs he
sometimes overcome by the longing for a
third state that relates to play as
floating dust to dancing as dancing dust
walking a blissful peaceful state of
motion it is the artists and
philosophers vision of happiness this is
one of the instances where niches genius
loses from every word a man of his
magnitude you couldn't really refrain
from philosophizing on the connection
between work boredom and plain work is
the result of a drive enacted by our
desire to satisfy a need when that need
is satisfied boredom creeps in in an
attempt to shift our awareness towards a
different need in that context boredom
becomes one of the most beneficial
elements in a person's life
boredom morphs into the catalyst for the
pursuit of higher needs and aspirations
in Friedrich Nietzsche's words to escape
boredom man works either beyond what his
usually needs require or else he invents
plain that is work that is designed to
quiet no need other than that for
working in general notice here that
Nietzsche considers play a viable
alternative to boredom and doing so he
elevates play to a higher level then he
goes on to suggest that there is
actually one more level a person can
reach that enhances the idea of play
that level is not precisely named and in
my regard the philosopher does so
because he considers that state and need
using Craddock one
every one of us bears the responsibility
for defining that state which results as
Nietzsche points out in a blissful
peaceful state of motion it is the
artists and philosophers vision of
happiness human all too human contains
around 638 Maxim's some aphorisms might
be considered a classic for some but all
we know the book can be characterized as
a legendary compendium of knowledge and
wisdom my hope with this video was to
shed some light on parts of the history
ideas and style that distinguished this
prolific figure and help you draw
inspiration from his life and teachings
growing up I realized that you should
choose your idols wisely Friedrich
Nietzsche is certainly one of my wisest
picks heroine what an intense video this
is by far my favorite philosopher and it
was really important for me to attempt
even a partial analysis of one of his
most important works human all too human
is a work of unprecedented beauty it is
not just philosophy in this poetry of
the most sublime form as always as a
huge thank you for watching and helping
this channel grow I have another
giveaway for you I was in the copy of
human all too human to one of you so you
can have a taste of Nietzsche's intense
world all you need to do is like
subscribe follow me on Instagram and
message me on Instagram confirming that
you did all that with a screenshot you
can also check out the details in the
description below the winner will be
announced in a week from now in my
Instagram account good luck to everyone
stay tuned thanks for watching see you
soon
[Music]